Peter King you're in person good to see
you Peter rich thank you for having me
it's great to be here is you know now
there's a reason to come to Los Angeles
for football two teams I love that two
teams I really love that and we were
talking about that folks across the
country best get ready for the power of
the NFL to be West and the Western time
zone would you agree with that no
question about it I I'm a little I was
at the 49ers yesterday I would be a
little worried about their skill
position depth and worried that their
defensive line which they've spent so
much draft capital on is maybe not gonna
be the premier unit that everybody has
thought that it would although DeForest
Buckner is very very good I I'm just
I'd be I'd be a little concerned
especially in their backfield you know
they're top two backs now MacKinnon and
breeder both hurt but look Jimmy
Garoppolo is a rising tide that lifts
all boats it's helped me out - what
isn't what's to be believed and how good
he is and that he's just you know the
football equivalent of hearing the crack
of the bat in the end okay rich you know
how you know how actors you know how you
know you've been around Kyle Shanahan
people sometimes when they they asked me
about certain guys somebody said to me
out in in San Francisco yesterday hey
what do you think of the job Shanahan is
doing and I said I think he's doing a
great job and they said what's he like
and I said he's skeptical because that's
what he is he he does not buy into
things right away and so you remember
when they made this trade last year at
you okay when they made this trade I was
convinced that Kyle Shanahan wanted to
go all-in on Kirk Cousins in free agency
in 2018 but when they traded for him I
said there had to have been a little bit
of a buy-in from him but I was told at
that time that all this means is that
they've spent a second round draft
choice and are gonna see this guy for
the next two months and then they'll
make their decision well after they
played I think it was ten
see he walked into John Lynch's office
last year said yes Shanahan walked into
John Lynch's off as a general manager
and he said hey let's get this guy
signed let's let's let's get this guy
done and that to me said everything
because that if you know Kyle Shanahan
you know that you have to do a lot of
convincing to make him love somebody and
it didn't take him long it only took him
a few games to understand that this guy
not only is he smart in football but
he's also the kind of field general the
Cheney and believes he needs so Peter
King what is more likely to happen Jimmy
Garoppolo brings Lombardi to the 49ers
or we find out the real reason why
Belichick Oh God only a second-round
pick much more likely that he wins a
Super Bowl because there's only about
three people who know the answer to this
question
there's Lynch there's Belichick well
Lynch might not not know he might not
even know I think I think Lynch knows
because he told me last year at the time
he says feeder I can't go there so I
think he why why only a second round
choice correct yeah in other words not
only not only why only a second round
choice but think about it
Belichick at the time knew that if he
put Garoppolo on the open market he
probably could have gotten a 1 plus
something from the Cleveland Browns and
why did he not do that I have my pet
theory a lot of people like to say hey
Belichick hates the Browns because they
fired him once I really don't think
that's it I think that Belichick truly
likes Jimmy Garoppolo and wanted to do
him a solid first of all and I think the
second reason is if Garoppolo did go to
Cleveland even if the Patriots got a
much better draft pool or draft
compensation for him he's very dubious
about whether Garoppolo would have
signed long term with Cleveland so what
happens if Garoppolo is ever a free
agent out of Cleveland well look at it
right now as of this year anyway Bills
needed a quarterback Jets needed a
quarterback and next year Miami might
need a quarterback so why would you why
would
you risk putting him in your own
division but that's just a little pet
theory that I have well I mean I'm
probably four people if you say Lynch
knows it be Kraft Belichick Brady and
and then Lynch and then they the
interesting thing though is cuz this is
why I always say in-between confetti
coming down in the Superbowl in training
camp windows opening up you have to put
in perspective any NFL story
how will it manifest itself when the
season starts playing because here we
are
Brady's 41 and just got you know I guess
more incentive Laden con right don't
like Bello checks not going anywhere
craft is sitting in the front office
there's Gronk back there they're all
ready to go again and in a division that
you've pointed out in mind-blowing
fashion over the last 15 years in and if
you pointed out in your football morning
in America column a couple weeks ago the
Patriots are 80 games better than the
next
it's I love about that the stat I love
about that one is for the Jets to Eve
get even with the Patriots they'd have
to go 80 you know in the next five years
of the Patriots would have to go oh and
80 I wish it wasn't hey but don't you
want to know my Michigan trivia yes I do
but I'm I do want to okay alright and in
that I want it I will definitely want to
get to that K but just to continue this
conversation and with Peter King here so
yes but the only team that I think that
that that has equal footing with New
England and I know that this is
potentially heresy to say this with the
Pittsburgh Steelers is Jacksonville
because they're young and they're hungry
and they're really really good what the
hell just happened I don't think that's
a great question I read about it this
morning I thought I heard about it last
night I didn't write anything about it I
was just up to my rear end in alligators
last night but what happened to me after
I read about it it looks like it was
sort of a brawl that got out of control
at training camp and then coach couldn't
stop well there's also the video that
we're seeing right now on the screen
that was taken by a Jacksonville comm
reporter who Jalen then tweeted at
basically saying you know calling the
reporter out for actually posting it
and all of a sudden then he's suspended
look it's a week and in preseason
football which is kind of like a paid
vacation in a way like enjoyed not being
here when it's a hundred degrees out and
playing in a meaningless game that can
only be meaningful if you get hurt so
and they they they called him for
conduct unbecoming not conduct
detrimental which means they don't have
they're not gonna take away any brain
bonus money right so this might be all
much ado about nothing would you would
you agree at least agree with my
assessment that I'm just gonna make this
point I'd be more worried about Fowler
okay here's a guy who has not in any way
sort of played up to his draft status
you know his first-round draft status
and he's yeah I'm when I read he was
suspended I said is this guy ever just
going to report to work come and play
games and be great or are we always
gonna be hearing about these little
things with this guy and and again I I
don't really know Fowler at all but I
would be more concerned about him Jalen
Ramsey it strikes me from my reading of
it and probably even that it looked as
though he just got really ticked off and
couldn't control himself but those are
not good things especially if you're
Doug Marrone you have a reputation of
running a tight shift it's a tight ship
if you're Tom Coughlin you were on a
tight ship this happening under the air
watch is pretty strange to me Peter King
hanger on the show we'll take a
60-second break come back hit the poll
question I want that Michigan trivia and
I want to know what you visited 14 camps
what people come up to you from coaching
stabs and front office's asking what are
people talking about yeah entering the
season and which team has got the most
buzz behind it Peter King at Peter
underscore King on Twitter back in 60
seconds with him with icecube right
behind Peter King right here on the Rich
Eisen show ask him the poll question
based off of that soundbite entering our
second second with Peter okay Peter what
is the biggest NFL preseason week one
overreaction that Baker Mayfield
completed 55% of his passes in his first
NFL outing
and was immediately fitted for the gold
Jackie hold on in the locker room after
the game okay let me give you the
options week one overreactions Baker
Mayfield should start for the Browns say
Quan Barclay will be an all-pro this
year
Vikings are the Superbowl favorite
beastmode is back and the helmet rule
will ruin the season well I'm gonna give
you mayfield but the second one on that
list will be the helmet rule will ruin
the season because and the helmet rule
is going to be impactful I was at a game
Saturday night in Phoenix oh that ring
lyndale I know your table that was
horrendous first of all I mean some of
the calls are horrendous but I'm just
saying there's 32 flags in that game
rich 32 flags including five in the last
minute 59 people in the stands and John
Perry and his crew or just it's a flag
first why why well because you know you
you you know rich that every year in the
preseason they tell officials err on the
side of throwing the flag we want to set
the example we want guys to know on
these rules clarifications what we're
gonna call this year and how aggressive
we're gonna be and I do think that
helmet rule you know look I had on my
trip I had one coach say to me that he
said he said players come to him in
training camp this year and just say I
just want to know do you want me to
change the way I play they said no do
not want to change okay I just want to
know that because at some point I'm
probably gonna get kicked out of a game
because there's no way you can play
football without banging your helmet on
somebody else well that Shamar Co Thomas
hit on on David Moore alright the we're
sure Marco Thomas if the Colts got
ejected for hitting doing more of the
Seahawks
that is the exact play they want out of
football yes and so that that's fine but
the AJ Thomas play that you're referring
to in our party AJ Howard play that
you're referring to on hit Shawn Culkin
and that Cardinals Chargers game that
that's absurd that's a ball play yeah
that but those are the kind of plays in
my opinion rich those are the kind of
plays that when they watch tape they're
gonna say shouldn't have thrown this
flag thus the that's why you call it an
overreaction saying it's gonna ruin the
game exactly because I believe what's
going to happen is that twice a week
you're gonna say oh my god that was a
horrible horrible call
it's not gonna be 16 times a week okay
twice a week
well when the season starts Peter King
here in the Rich Eisen show the reason
why we did not include Josh Rosen in
there is because coming out of the draft
everyone was assuming he was gonna be
the most game ready ready for play NFL
ready
quarterback how did he look to you in
that he didn't play particularly well
but the one thing that I really liked
when I watched him very confident and I
don't mean in a cocky way I mean he got
under center and he got in the shotgun
and he basically had no I don't want to
say no fear but I mean it looked like
he'd been doing this for a long time so
I talked to him after the game and he is
not even remotely cowed or intimidated
and you know the book on Josh Rosen
obviously is that you know he's a little
bit full of himself I I talked to two
guys who I've known for quite a while in
that locker room and they like Josh
Rosen it's early but we'll see and Baker
Mayfield fitted for the gold jack I hate
him I thought he made two or three great
passes but but here's the thing you know
Hugh Jackson told me something really
good in Cleveland camp he goes look
Baker Mayfield is gonna thank me one day
for starting his career on the bench and
I think everybody said what what why
would you say that right because if you
look at the way this sport is is played
and look at the complexity of this game
particularly from a guy who played in
that offensive system at Oklahoma and
needs a lot of work in the mental part
of his game look what happened a Carson
Palmer in 2003 it's only 15 years ago
and Carson Palmer had a redshirt year
and went on to have an above-average two
very good NFL career at quarterback
and he credits in part being able to
really learn every
thing before he had to play if I was
Baker Mayfield I'm not saying I wouldn't
want to play of course you want to play
but if I'm Baker may feel there's
definitely a silver lining and sitting
Peter King here on the Rich Eisen show
the one team nobody's talking about that
should be talked about is who the
Baltimore Ravens why is that Joe Flacco
is playing excellent football in train
in training camp what does that mean I
don't know what it means but he's sooo
supremely motivated I don't want to say
to stick it up their rear ends because
that's not exactly right he's supremely
motivated to say oh you draft a
quarterback number one I'm gonna make
him sit for the next five years well the
last time that happened they won the
Super Bowl behind him yeah when they
pissed him off and now that improves on
you watch this guy and I was talking to
Larry Fitzgerald about this because he
was in Arizona you watched John Brown if
John Brown stays healthy I'm telling you
right now John Brown the wide receiver
former Cardinal stays healthy and he
just I'm saying on September second
fourth fifth whenever you have your
fantasy draft pick him in the 11th round
and thank me later okay all right well
where do you take Lamar Jackson then cuz
they can't keep a margin filled Peter
Lamar Jackson is footballs version of
Otani he is he's gonna make some
incredible plays but is he ever gonna be
able to stick him in your lineup I guess
that's what I'm saying you know
everybody was so excited I'm a big
rotisserie baseball player and everybody
was so excited before the year about
Otani but I said is he gonna get enough
at-bats and is he gonna pitch enough to
be a big factor in fantasy rotisserie
baseball no and no but the Ravens can't
keep this kid off the field they can't
they can't he's too dynamic but but good
one person can play quarterback at once
he's not gonna start the year as the
quarterback Joe Flacco is gonna get the
opportunity to keep him from because
here's what's gonna happen they will do
what Marty morning wake did in
Philadelphia eight or nine years ago
when he was trying to just sort of get
Michael Vick on the field at the time
when they had Donovan McNabb remembered
McNabb was the quarterback
he's the exact same situation that that
flock goes in right now McNab started
but Vic would come in as a change of
pace guy and maybe 1012 snaps a game I
forget how many played that's the way I
think at first anyway they'll use
Jackson a couple more minutes left with
Peter King here in studio what are
people coming up to you and asking you
like coaches cuz this is such a chatty
league maybe at what is water folks in a
league picking your brain about I had a
coach yesterday asked me called me on
the phone and asked me what can we do to
stop this anthem thing it's just it's
all anybody's talking about my players
are talking about it
that's all I read about we're playing
football games and everybody's talking
about who's kneeling who's sitting we
got to stop this we got it and I said I
don't know the answer to the question I
don't know because we're this one off
the rails in my opinion is last year
when the NFL handed the players the
players coalition 90 million dollars
over seven years basically as an as a
gesture of goodwill and say here go work
on your social causes and expected that
the anthem issue would go away it hasn't
gone away it still isn't going away and
I think even if Goodell and D Smith do
make some sort of deal that it's not
gonna stop the more militant militant
the more avid kneelers sitters locker
room guys from doing what they want to
do well you and I talked about this on
your podcast we taped to something
before you came on here and your podcast
can be gotten on any since Wednesday
okay not on NBC Sports it's just
independent okay the Peter King podcast
and stuff like that okay where to me the
players and the management Union and the
front office of the NFL getting together
and coming together and doing something
together would be monster big yeah just
monster big whatever it is if if Trump
complains about it so be it if fans
still complain about it so be it if some
players complain about it so be it it's
got to get you it's got to be a group
effort
correct got to be a group effort so so
just like it was in the NBA lockout
potentially coming in three years from
now because the NBA has a more stringent
rule right now and you don't see
anything in the NBA or hear anything in
the NBA on this particular subject
except to say our house is fine and
we're still talking about social issues
right because there's a trust level
between players and management that is
lacking in the NFL yeah something's got
to be hammered out before but
something's got to be done as I said my
column today you know basically where is
Roger Roger Goodell is the highest-paid
Commissioner in the history of American
sports and he can't solve this problem
well that's what a commissioner needs to
do in tough times he needs to solve
problems I think this is I mean it's
bull this is this has to be owned by a
lot of people but mostly in my opinion
this is on the doorstep of Roger Goodell
now obviously some players might be
listening to this also saying the way to
fix it is to have people stop getting
shot that's why it's a very very
difficult issue extremely different
so before I before you go sir what's
your Michigan trivia that I need to know
about please my Michigan trivia and I
just remembered when in the middle of
this segment that oh my god I wrote this
in my column recently see you may know
that Jim Harbaugh lives four houses down
from Bo Schembechler house in Ann Arbor
his children go to the same elementary
schools as he went to so when people say
Harbaugh he's gone Indianapolis he's
going to wherever I now I've started to
think not so fast cowboy Peter his
parents live across the driveway they
have next door to each other
yeah Jim Harbaugh's children can go into
his backyard and Grandma and Grandpa
watched them from their kitchen why
would he leave anything like that I
don't know that's what that was someone
I read all of us he's making a jillion
dollars isn't he I mean whatever he's
making it's redic and he's not having
chicken right did you read that he
didn't read this no why is he nervous
bird will in spate and now is the
quarterback out here for Chip Kelly yeah
it looks like Wilton spade former
Michigan quarterback now out here at
UCLA said Harbaugh once told him no
chicken because it's a nervous bird
don't eat in there uh nervous bird ha ha
ha ha I had no idea how
not eat chicken hey work for Wade Boggs
no come on
3,000 hits and Wade Boggs and like 80
light beers to go hung chicken oh I
guess I'll ask you the question Don
Bowie are coordinated reduce yeah Jetson
Meyer wants me to ask every single guest
question which Harbaugh needs to win
more this year Jim or John John everyone
says John John but she loves him though
really loves him but I think if they go
six and ten he's gonna say no wait a
second
last is it last five years it'll be the
last last six years they would be either
right at 500 or below with one playoff
on the street for two minutes wouldn't I
agree I would I really really have high
regard for John Harbaugh but I'm just
saying in the immortal words of Lord
King I'm just saying
yes my daughter used to always say that
I'm just saying no it's a great caveat
you see whatever the hell you want to
say after he needs to win he needs to
great to see you Peter thank you no
thanks for inviting me anytime anytime I
check out Peter on Twitter at Peter
underscore king is podcast available on
Apple podcast football morning in
America on NBC sports.com and football
night in America coming up on Sundays
great to see you Thank You Richie you
bet we're back again IceCube will be
here in studio our number two and then
Alex Cora of Peter Kings Boston Red Sox
50 games above 500 heads too ridiculous
skipper will be joining us our three the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience